un viaje para asentar las bases de la
diplomacia en medio de una creciente
amenaza violenta el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden llegó Este
martes a Irlanda del Norte en la primera
parada de una visita de cuatro días a
las dos partes de la isla el objetivo
destacar el papel que ha jugado la
nación norteamericana en el
mantenimiento de la paz tras 25 años
desde los acuerdos de viernes santo que
acabaron con 30 años de violencia entre
un guionistas y republicanos cuando el
presidente visite Islandia del Norte
Ahora que está en una situación bastante
buena comparada con la que podría haber
tenido porque tenemos un acuerdo entre
el Reino Unido y la Unión Europea
elogiar al Primer Ministro por ello creo
pero también le instala a él y a los
partidos locales a que vuelven a
repartirse El Poder y hagan que las
instituciones democráticas funcionen
correctamente Mientras tanto en belfas
la presencia de agentes en las calles
sea multiplicado para garantizar la
seguridad ante la visita del mandatario
estadounidense que el miércoles se
reunirá con el Premier británico Richie
sunak en la capital nori irlandesa en
las últimas jornadas ante los eventos
conmemorativos por los 25 años de paz
entre las dos irlandes ha habido conatos
de violencia de grupos republicanos sin
embargo El sentir mayoritario de la
sociedad ante la llegada de vaivén es
positivo
creo que es muy positivo que el
presidente de Estados Unidos venga a
visitar Irlanda del Norte hoy y con
suerte alentará a nuestros políticos a
sentarse a la mesa y hacer que funcione
realmente pude estimular las cosas y tal
vez Estas tomen un rumbo un poco más
serio y necesitamos ayuda ahora mismo
para poner todo en orden y quizás esto
le dará la gente el impulso que necesita
bailen también visitar a dublín en los
próximos días se dirigirá ante el
parlamento nacional y estará Asimismo en
su ciudad natal ancestral donde miles de
personas esperan su llegada